Nevada State Police tell us they're
responding to a 14-car crash in the
South Valley this is near where the
southern part of the 215 meets the I-15
Madison Kimbrough tracking things on the
roads for us this evening she joins us
live in that area with more Madison
today's weather causing a traffic
headache for those driving right here on
the 215 Southern Beltway you can kind of
see what we're talking about behind me
but take a look at our fast cam where
you can see a better view of the 14 car
pileup that you just mentioned all cars
move to the right side of the road with
multiple drivers transported to the
hospital with non-life-threatening
injuries it's unclear how this crash
occurred but it's likely due to the rain
and wet conditions out on our roadways
as of now four lanes are blocked off and
one lane remains open so if you are
headed this way expect delays of the RTC
of southern Nevada also reporting
several other crashes across the valley
that we are keeping our eye on as you
can see the westbound Lanes here on the
215 are currently open reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now